clock drop a little bit more than 30
minutes away for the knights as they get
ready to take on the canadians for game
two
let's check in one last time with ryan
loftus out at t-mobile arena brian
denise it is such a festive atmosphere
you too is playing people are really
flying in i'm going hey quick interview
we got a great family here
[Music]
they're literally queued up they're
pre-cued up they're ready to go
i got to ask you one quick question you
said is this the hottest
pre-game for hockey ever your take
unverified 100
absolutely flippin hot yes ted florento
is in there and he is standing by
searching but we've only had hockey for
four years i think this may be it
that's crazy hot dude last question
flurry block 29 shots only let in one
goal in game one can you do it again
one goal is fine here's my prediction
five three bgk you guys go have fun
a family affair with the go knights go
ready
it was an unbelievable performance in
game one everybody
the canadians was going who are these
golden knights
can they do it again we're so excited to
see if that's going to be the case
as the golden knights move through the
semifinals
i'm not quite sure who i'm tossing